es una tradición consagrada en la
constitución de eeuu el discurso anual
del presidente sobre el estado de la
unión los padres fundadores
establecieron que el presidente debe
informar al congreso sobre el estado del
país y recomendar las medidas que
consideren necesarias y oportunas pero
no fue sino hasta el siglo pasado que lo
que era un simple reporte escrito se
transformó en un espectáculo moderno de
poderío presidencial además de las dos
cámaras del congreso se invita a la
corte suprema- al cuerpo diplomático a
la junta de jefes del estado mayor y a
todo el gabinete del presidente excepto
al superviviente designado el sucesor
oficial del presidente en caso de
catástrofe el primer estado de la unión
de joe biden coincide con una coyuntura
delicada una población exhausta por la
pandemia preocupada por la creciente
inflación por el aumento del gas y la
guerra en ucrania
no hay duda de que el discurso será un
poco diferente de lo que habría sido
hace unos meses siempre hay referencias
a la seguridad nacional en cada discurso
sobre el estado de la unión pero cada
uno refleja un momento en el tiempo
observer fax
by then tendrá que enfrentarse al
balance de sus meses de mandato
intentando celebrar éxitos como el
nombramiento de la primera mujer
afroestadounidense a la corte suprema- y
reconociendo las dificultades que
persisten además de la mención a ucrania
se espera que el presidente insista en
su estancada agenda económica interna y
que detalle sus planes para atajar la
inflación y la criminalidad una encuesta
reciente de eivissa news y el washington
post revela que sólo el 37 por ciento de
los estadounidenses aprueba el trabajo
de byd en algunos miembros del partido
demócrata esperan que el discurso
propulsar a la difícil presidencia